I was like well here we are taking one
of our world-famous breaks filming with
a nice bit of weather for it you know
yep stay nice and rainy we thought we'd
get their fancy shiner out and have a
little bit cokes call flowers on it as a
what's that it's a tea strainer strainer
put some coke in there yeah up are we
done I just wrecked the table clock
that's no good we should change this
table puffs yeah but I can't be bothered
to move all of this laid out stuff it's
so pretty I know
bye dear
osteo well some of it still the table
well that was a bit disappointing
because nothing broke so I think of what
we do is just to get a bit of smashing
action from this video it's give it a
right good messing up ready yeah
well that works a treat
as you can see took care of those two
that look we geniusly put down this
ground sheet to catch all the pieces but
as you can see that's quite in the wrong
place but I get cleaning
yep look at the fat it's got shiner in
it give it a little row tight or wedge
dinner look at that Oh gnarly